[Music]
so this guy who is a co-owner of a dog
food company decided to do a 30-day
challenge only eating his company from
food hmm I think that's fine I get it
you standing by this product you said
much it's so good a human to eat it yeah
I get it
did he die is he allowed to like if you
louder like cook it and like eat up in a
frying pan or something did you see him
prepare it okay do see him like have
boiling water and like put in hob is
that how the dogs good eat it
cuz I know with gravy train you can add
water to it every time you ever have a
dog and feed it gravy train what is it
it's a really white trash dog food
basically it's if you put your pour it
right and then you add water to it so it
looks like it's gravy oh and is that
like it's like a is it a dry one or a
mushy it's a dry dog food and then you
add water to it and it really does look
like crazy II only in color
ah the dogs like it I guess I think dogs
have to eat it well dogs eat dog [ __ ] so
I get it true yeah this isn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
my dog would wish it was catch it catch
it big rose yeah anyway so Mitch here
who is the president of Munster milling
company he documented his 30 day
challenge of only eating dog food I hope
to god it went viral cuz then he did
that [ __ ] for no reason I mean we're
talking about it now what if you got
fleas removed yeah he's like alright
guys well here's how he's like my teeth
are very tart or strong
really you guys didn't hear behind the
camera case you said that the video only
had 3,000 views
well which one did you there's three
videos week one week let me see one more
3000 TV right now there is three so no
one even cares that this guy did this
last this guy then you could say no one
really cares or you could say 3000
people died in 9/11 isn't that a lot of
people there's a lot of people but I see
it compared to let's check yourself
millions it doesn't matter how many
people died in New York pal that's not
I'm saying I'm saying 2,000 I look a lot
of people look at how smart he is he
prepped this joke even came with this
joke premeditated jokes for JK news dude
Mehcad never have it so I got this an
airport well no one we're in New York
briefly
were you like 3,000 because I dressed
it's like what you said earlier it's
like what you said your black clothes in
an airport just so you can make that
joke thought about it on the plane let
me look at my dick let me get my next
joke ready I checked their YouTube page
and most of their videos have like two
views by views so 3,000 is a lot this is
viral for him by shirt think it is he
despairs the victim video we're gonna go
to some views he really stands by his
product yeah guys come on guys dark meat
anymore dogs we please we let the men
sell a couple bags
he's like addicted to it now let me show
you guys the videos but give plots with
TVs an intervention here we go
come on Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
what if this guy was like oh this
marketing campaign is genius we got to
reach out to influencers and we start
getting dm's about hey would you guys be
down to try dog fur for 30 days I guess
that's like this guy I know someone who
would
wow that was instant for me oh so true
yeah so then it was funny because uh
some of the like the customer relations
manager said the president's crazy
[ __ ] coat is really shiny now we've
noticed that his hair is getting thicker
believe growing Wow his dating looks
more like lipstick lipstick e these days
thirty pounds oh no [ __ ]
wait is that too fast too much to about
30 pounds in 30 days yeah cuz he's not a
[ __ ] obese no I mean it's that's a
good amount of weight he lost well he
didn't eat much then healthy guys I mean
it's got a it's hard to define health
you got it I needed to look at much
other stats I got all the other stats
I'm in your head man I run that [ __ ] BMI
and his clown body body fat percentage
Bart keeps trying to have his image of a
clown but if you look at it he refuses
to accept what he is actually putting
out he thinks that what he put out ten
years ago two years now it's it's funny
fit stuff I don't even have a
discontinue anyway so yeah I mean it I
thought it was kind of cool that this
dude stood by his company like that and
it's kind of extreme but yeah I mean
it's like you look he probably thought
it was gonna go super viral and like
definitely quicken and seeing it's only
a few thousand views is a little uh
sadly disappointing for him I think it's
quite a bit yeah with maybe they didn't
pay for the the push the promotion
uh-huh what can you do it I mean damn
eating dog food for 30 days it sounds
like I mean how did you even hear about
his article uh
across in our submissions one one of you
guys out there yeah one of those
positive searching through cat forums
and they're [ __ ] on this guy this
[ __ ] dog loser I'm a dog lover but ya
know it's uh it's Fort Worth muse not a
lot not a lot going on over there huh
so what do you do to top this if you're
at their company you're like [ __ ] that
didn't work what do we do to top this
candy sounds like he really made a
commitment that he wasn't sure he could
follow well I'm gonna eat the [ __ ] for
30 days yeah and later he's like [ __ ]
did I say 30 man Oh every day and I was
wondering if he ate anything else or is
it like I'm gonna eat a can of dog food
I mean he lost 30 pounds look like he
was oh yes dog food oh he's going a
hunger strike until people buy his
product oh yeah there you go
please buy my [ __ ] I haven't eaten in
five days so we don't have any orders I
like commitment to his brand they really
stand behind I like to blow up in his a
week three video this week three video
he's like well I mean we made the [ __ ]
cuz he's wearing this shirt that says
hashtag 30 days of dog food hashtag
empty the bowl hashtag monster hashtags
might be a stand behind your brand and
then he was like well we made the shirts
I got oh here's where we [ __ ] up he
should've did a this was like a month
documentary like documenting his whole
process instead of being like up to date
here this week I only ate dog foods week
two I'm only documents like are we get a
dog you're only eating dog food do his
marketing something I would have had a
doggy mukbangs like he's [ __ ] the pie
light was it was his lab coming out
right the lab was like yeah the real
celebrities out now yeah the one I like
is when they put the dog head but it's
the human body so it could be like that
I love it that I'm better than him
digesting it Steve suggested just give
it to your own dog for 30 what's wrong
with that it's like you know because I
always use big dog food companies and
yeah it doesn't seem like they're making
great stuff all the time like just it's
like hey we gave this to our own animals
yeah cuz I should I doubt pedigrees
giving their dog I doubt it do I bet
they had their own [ __ ] celebrity
chefs and [ __ ] or if you eat it don't
try to look like you're about to throw
up yeah it's real ha leave it in that
makes all [ __ ] angry come on Mitch it
makes me think of your product as
hurting my dog's stomach tube how I bet
you Burger King they don't feed their
food to the kids see mr. King doesn't do
that but yeah so they're saying this
whole challenge here what the ended up
doing is partnering up with Pet Supplies
Plus to cover the first $100 for every
adoption at this one event called
operation kindness which are they know
killed at a no-kill shelter called
Operation kindness and Texas so at least
this kind of has a little bit of that
that good stuff doing it all wrong
they're like going in so many different
directions right now like their heart is
in the right place they just need a
[ __ ] focus on that one thing
not like maybe we could help them with
their marketing tell you man one video
this is my journey of eating dog food
for 30 days that [ __ ] would have got at
least 4,000 days there's like Burton GOP
and I hate come to barbell we're we're
seeing a commercial we're gonna be going
to our own gym every day isn't there in
the gym like smoking cool
oh wow these weights are cold too like
oh this is really weak this is slippery
the bars really slippery right right
it's terrible marketing what have him
eventually we evolved like society of
marketing and advertising evolves to a
point where it people only talk about
the negatives and then they compare well
that's not that bad I can live with
those negative points
that'll never happen think it's going in
that way welcome to Joe security where
sometimes we catch the bad guys
[Laughter]
[Music]